[Music]
thank you
hey what's up it's so funny because I
never really get to see that that crit
that was pretty cool it's awfully bright
in here that light back there like
changed Colors oh it's because that that
was to added some more there we go back
there want some mood lighting did this
can that thing come down a little bit
what just uh the ring light no it don't
[__] with it because it's just you know
what I mean actually no it looks good
yeah that's what I no I wasn't talking
about that light I was talking about
that light oh okay that light changed
color right now
like a few minutes ago why'd you change
color I don't know you didn't tell it
too right no I didn't touch it
ghost I guess it does that periodically
it just decides oh I'm gonna be a
different color today all right so it
turned like blue or whatever so I'm
looking at the monitor because it was
red lighting level looks normal now well
yeah and that's because I turned the
ring light down two things too okay
that's why that's why
so uh so yeah it's a haunting Mondays as
usual on Mondays
and uh this episode I thought that we
had done because this is um
this story was also on a Paranormal
Witness too right and I think it was on
a couple of other paranormal shows
because the guy wrote a book about it
you know what I mean so I think he made
the rounds and I looked up our
past shows and we did do a show about uh
this case but it was way back I think it
was episode 76 or something like that so
I figured ah why the hell not we can
redo it the weird thing about this
though is that on the Wikipedia page
there's a Wikipedia page that's just
called list of Haunting episodes
and on the Wikipedia page it has this
episode listed as House of Horrors
but actually on the disc itself that we
have and in other places like on IMDb
and stuff it's actually listed as the
haunting of the Allen house
so yeah it is true they said you look
like you're wearing a burqa I did
because of the is it because this thing
on the back your chair baby well I don't
know that's what it was I'm not wearing
a burka I'm just wearing a dress with
like a high yeah yeah neck that's all
and there was a
a sweater on the back of the chair yeah
that was probably what it was too he
gave you that damn
shape
burka shape
but yeah so is Zach the only one here
he's the only one talking
nice people never okay
I wasn't really sure nah
so uh are you gonna help me talk about
this episode we watched it too right
yeah we've seen this one
it's a good episode
uh Danny Rowling said The smurl Haunting
case for a Wednesday show would be sick
I thought we already did this moral
haunting to be honest with you and I
thought it wasn't that long ago which
almost smile
I can't remember but I'm pretty sure I'm
pretty sure we've done that case before
and I thought we had done it fairly
recently we either did it kind of
recently or we did it like a really long
time ago I know that name but this one
like I said we did talk about the Allen
House haunting
um but I think it was episode 76 if I'm
not mistaken it was it was a long time
ago it was like the first year that we
were doing the stuff because this case
like I said the guy Mark Spencer
who supposedly experienced the [__] uh
wrote a book about it back in 2012 what
the hell is it called I have it written
down a haunted love story The Ghost of
the Allen house and uh so he was like I
said around 2012 he was doing the rounds
of all the paranormal shows so I know
that we saw this version which was on a
haunting and there was a version that
was on Paranormal Witness and he might
have been on another one as well if I'm
not mistaken so he was just kind of like
all over the place
uh Dana Rolex said no we never did the
small haunting he said but you did
review the movie that was about the case
the haunted from 1991. okay well that's
what I was thinking of then because I
guess we kind of like talked about the
real case when we talked about that I
don't remember the episode that much I
remember the name if somebody would
remind me what was on that episode I'd
remember yeah it's not it's part it's a
pretty good
so yeah so this uh episode right here
season five episode four
is uh you know they so they do like the
um you know the Flash Forward like they
usually do and in this case they always
pick out like the most exciting couple
minutes and it was a part where the
woman like saw a ghost in the hallway or
something a lot of people see in
apparitions in this one and the thing
about it is that I guess before the
couple who are like at the center of
this episode before they even moved in I
guess this house was already kind of
famous for being haunted so I'm not
really sure if they
they claimed they claimed not to know it
going in I mean you know what I mean
like well I mean they knew it late like
before they bought the house obviously
because people told them but I don't
know if they knew like specifically
before they bought it and they were like
hey you know what I mean
I'm at you know I'm not saying that I
don't know if they did that so yeah so
this is Mark and Rebecca Spencer uh are
the name of the couple
so they do this Flash Forward thing like
with the um with the woman saying a
ghost and all that kind of [__] and then
it's like one year earlier you know what
I mean so this happened in 2005 in a
place called Monticello Arkansas
so I guess Mark was
um he's a professor I'm not sure of what
but he'd been um working in like
universities and stuff for like a really
long time like a couple of decades and I
guess he had been working in Oklahoma
but I guess he got a job in Arkansas so
they were looking around like for a
place to live in Arkansas so they see
this Mansion the Allen house uh while
they're out walking and they were like
it's really unique it's actually got
quite a beautiful house um you know what
I mean like you know there's pictures of
it all over the Internet so you can
there's not a secret it's pretty famous
so um but yeah it is actually a really
beautiful mansion it's pretty huge
so they saw it and they got really
um Jazz about and they're like wow
that's a gorgeous house and they just
said they felt really drawn to it and
drawn to the town in general so the next
day Mark accepts the job in Arkansas
that he's been uh offered
and they go to see the house and they
were like they really really wanted it
apparently though
um something that was stopping them was
that somebody already lived in the [__]
like the house wasn't for sale you know
what I mean they were just basically
like walking by and they're like we're
gonna buy that out from underneath
whoever lives there I was like that's
kind of not cool but whatever
um now they did say once Mark said once
he got closer to the house
um you know he's like it looked really
beautiful from far away but it's like
you got close up and it looks kind of
gloomy and uh it was a little bit
dilapidated
um and like I said someone lives there
so he just decided Well I'm just gonna
go up and knock on the door and see if I
can talk to the person that lives there
and maybe talk them into selling it to
me or whatever so the first time he goes
up to the house though he just goes up
to the door and he can hear like a radio
playing inside and he's like the radio
was playing this real scary like fire
and brimstone kind of you know kind of
the [__] that was on the radio in the
car and Children of the Corn you know
what I mean it was like that it was like
that kind of crap and so he's like so
that freaked him out a little bit
because he's like who the [__] lives in
this house that's listening to that kind
of [__] like in the middle of the
afternoon which you know I understand
that that would be pretty frightening
but um as it was you know he just heard
the radio and like nobody answered the
door and he's kind of he was like well I
was kind of glad nobody answered the
door because I don't want to know who
the [__] was in there listen to this
stuff you know what I mean
so uh so yeah
he's like uh I don't know so he's
looking at the house and he's like look
he tells his wife he's like it kind of
looks like a money pit not gonna lie uh
but she was obsessed and she really
really wanted it so of course he's like
okay well I guess we have to have it the
house is on North Main Street by the way
so they decide to go to a realtor that
can maybe help them get in touch with
the owner and like see what the [__] is
going on and all that now the realtor
according to them straight up told them
oh the Allen house is haunted everybody
knows that it's very famous and uh she's
like also the house isn't for sale and
the woman who lives there would never
sell it to you so I really can't help
you in that regard
so at this point Mark gets kind of
curious about the house and starts
looking up the history like behind it
so he's like this house turns up on all
kind of paranormal sites uh it was built
in 1906 by a dude named Joe Lee Allen
who had three daughters one of the
daughters was named Liddell and that was
his uh favorite apparently
now she got married I guess at 19 and
then moved away but then got divorced
like not too long later so she ended up
like moving back in with her family like
into this house
and uh she very famously committed
suicide uh after her mother's Christmas
party one year and nobody really knew
why
so it was kind of like a famous story
like around town and everyone talked
about how creepy the house was and other
people had like seen things you know
what I mean like people in the windows
and [__] like that
so out of the blue the owner lady
actually calls mark one day and wants to
meet with them she says well I'm out of
town for several weeks but when I get
back
um you know I'll talk to you guys about
it and we'll see what we can sort out
but the weird thing about that is that
even though the owner was supposedly not
there and I guess you lived in the house
all by herself she was like kind of an
older lady not old old but she was like
a slightly older lady
but Mark and Rebecca like walk past the
house like in the street and they see a
woman like sitting up in the window of
like one of the bedrooms like she's
sitting at a desk writing or something
like that and they're like oh that must
be the owner she must be back or
something like that
but it turns out that when they actually
go to meet the owner they actually go to
the house to meet her
um the owner says that that wasn't her
because she just got back and the house
should have been empty so you know there
was that kind of creepy [__]
so they said when they first went in the
house Rebecca said it felt like really
magical they said it wasn't scary or
oppressive or nothing like that they
said it actually felt really warm and
really welcoming and they were really
into it and they said like the first
floor was actually really really
gorgeous now like the owner said you
know the second floor needs some work
it's you know not as in as good a shape
as the first floor but they're like it
was just a beautiful beautiful house
um so yeah so when they're giving like
the tour of the house they go to the
master bedroom and they see that window
and Mark says it's like oh you must have
like just moved all this stuff in here
he said because the how the master
bedroom where that window was where
they'd seen the lady from the street
they're like was just packed full of
boxes and there's like no desk in there
there was like no way anyone could have
been sitting in there so he was like oh
did you just move all this [__] in here
like after because we saw you sitting in
the window and she was like oh that
wasn't me you know she's like this crap
has been in here I haven't been in this
room for like years and years so she's
like well you must have just seen the
ghost that's all and she was like roll
you know kind of chill about it she's
like yeah a lot of people's eye and like
when I looked it up on the other
paranormal sites a lot of people did
that they'd seen a woman like in the
upper window like when they walk past
and [__] like that
so uh she's like yeah this place is
haunted everybody knows that she's like
I did have it exercised though so it
should be safe
um and then she also told them she
seemed a little weird you know what I
mean at least like the actor play the
actor's playing her she said the ghosts
used to talk all the time when I first
moved in but they don't talk so much
anymore
so at this point marker and Becca were
just kind of like looking at each other
like okay crazy lady like whatever you
say but you know they wanted to buy the
house so they were like well we were
just trying to be polite even though we
thought she was kind of like a weirdo
but then like the lady very surprisingly
says oh well I think the house likes you
and I think that God told me to sell the
house to you like it was some kind of
kismet or something like that like that
you guys you know were drawn here to the
specific thing and I'm supposed to sell
to you
yeah that's what she said this thing is
driving me crazy like hanging in the
[__] corner of the [__] and I can't
move it I can't move it how's that yeah
that's much better yeah that's driving
me crazy Julian Pope says a haunting
recycling actors again I recognize the
actress who plays Rebecca as ginger in
the Summer Wind episode yeah that's
right it's a regular cast yeah yeah yeah
that's right they yeah they always have
like uh kind of the same people yeah
when you're a fan of the series you're
waiting to see him again you're like hey
hey it's where's that raccoon guy he's
just a regular cast they just switch up
roles yeah
yeah I'm sure they just have like a
stable of few actors and they just use
the same ones over and over you just
call them up you know what I mean so uh
so yeah so she's like probably got a
contract
yeah and like they yeah they probably
like do so many yeah like how many
episodes they can do I mean I'm sure
they don't want like the same people
turning up every you know every single
episode but they definitely got regulars
yeah they definitely have but they're
like you know each season you can do two
episodes or three episodes or whatever
and they also tend to uh do [__] like do
shout outs and callbacks to earlier
[__] episodes they have it up and
[__] if you actually were to take the
the the
uh the soundscapes away or the [__]
scores a lot of this a lot of this
shit's [__] funny you could tell that
they're they're [__] goofing off when
they're with it but it's good it's good
yeah especially during the exorcism
[__] scenes and [__] you know I don't
know how they can keep it straight keep
it straight yeah like all the crazy [__]
I'd be like yeah I'm rebuking okay
that's just very very silly
so uh so yeah so this lady is basically
like yeah God said that I should sell
the house to you and they're like okay
fair enough so soon after that they
actually do buy the house I don't know
what happened to the lady afterward I
guess she just [__] off to Florida or
whatever like they all do when they get
old
so um then they're like as soon as we
moved in like we hadn't even finished
like renovating or nothing they're like
all the neighbors started like coming by
the house she said it started out like
that was like teenagers but then it was
like adults and [__] too and like they'd
come up to the porch and like knock on
the door and be like hey like we heard
that you were letting people come in
look at the haunted house and she was
like where the [__] did you get that
idea we didn't tell anybody right and
it's like well I guess that that
everybody was curious about the house
but I guess like the lady that had lived
there before like didn't want anybody
coming through I mean understandably you
don't want a bunch of strangers didn't
Hugo want a shirt yeah yeah who you who
goes in there yeah hey Hugo if you
wanted that uh pliskin shirt I got it
yeah we're just waiting for the address
and it really said it smells like roses
in here yeah let's explain that
explain it
yeah miss Warren would go down to the
[__]
local [__] Mobile gas station go in
there and get that car air freshener
yeah yeah
oh look the smell is sick
we exercised that [__] boom yeah because
I I explicitly remember that Rose was
one of the [__] scents when I was a
kid that you could buy yeah Pine Rose
and other [__] like musk well I hope
there's not one called other [__] yeah
other [__] yeah yeah I want the other
[__] flavor
smells like farts
they got people that are like that
they're gonna add to the Sparks
[__] wow [__] man maybe they're
thinking maybe they're thinking if my
car smells like farts all the time then
it's like I can fart with the community
and like no one can say anything by the
way that's just what my car smells like
I'm sorry yeah by the way I didn't fart
okay it's this hot new air freshener
called other [__]
it's not my [__]
so feel free
to let it rip yeah go to town yeah
because it's some other [__] let's do
the jingle whatever feel free to let it
rip because it's from other [__]
not gonna lie I'd probably buy that
I invented that [__] right here on the
spot like a million dollars with that
oh man
I kind of feel like that well I I don't
know like maybe the window for that has
passed because I do kind of feel like
there was kind of a mini uh boom lit in
like making products that were like
really gross like really stinky or
really like disgusting yeah the candy
that [__] tasted like boogers yeah
yeah I mean I know that they still have
that now because they they have that
Harry Potter like
um that bag of beans that some of it's
not like vomiting earwax and [__] I'm
like okay whatever
only little kid would like that well
yeah because little kids are gross yeah
that's why
uh Zach says y'all make a joke but I
still think you can make bank if you
invented air fresheners that SM that uh
smell like certain foods or just unusual
smells yeah yeah I mean I have seen
um I think I got my brother for
Christmas many years ago I got him some
bacon car air fresheners and they look
like little strips of bacon and you hung
them from your car thing and then it
smelled like bacon in your car so I was
into that
[__] squirt that [__] make it smell
like [__] french fries ooh I'd I'd be
down for that like just made the car
smell like McDonald's french fries all
the time KFC
yeah well I thought that I don't know if
it was KFC but I know that one of the
fast food places maybe it was KFC I know
one of the fast food places did do like
kind of a like a stunt promo thing where
they had like a perfume that spelled
like like fried chicken or something
like that I think I'm remembering that
right I know there was one that it was
one of those kind of like tie-in things
like ooh we're doing these crazy like
products you know what I mean
to get people to come into KFC but uh
but yeah so uh how do we get distracted
we were talking about other [__] talking
about yeah talk about other [__] yeah
and then we went off online it was funny
it always happens it always it was funny
though I went down there
and it's been the 80s Eddie Murphy would
have said some [__] like that made a
million dollars off of it had a whole
record album I know yeah now we just
like say comedy now we just say funny
[__] and only like a handful of people
here yeah and it passes and it doesn't
even become a cultural thing I know it's
not sad yeah we should we should be much
more famous yeah I feel like yeah
because Eddie Murphy [__] was funny when
you were a kid oh yeah we talk like that
all the time now yeah okay but uh yeah I
mean it was a big deal back then a big
deal back then yeah Danny Rowling said
stuffed peppers scented candles yeah
that would probably be pretty good too
well it smells like maybe like an
Italian restaurant or
I know they have pizza ones I've seen
those and I know they have bacon ones
because I've seen those as well but I
don't know about other ones
so uh so yeah
so like I said you have all these random
ass neighbors uh showing up on the
doorstep like hey can we come inside and
she's like absolutely not I don't know
who the [__] you people are
so uh yeah she's like there was just
people showing up all the time and they
didn't know what to do about it so they
start renovating the place so Mark is
like you know he works that he's a
professor like at the University or
whatever so he works like 50 60 hours a
week and then comes home and works on
the house so he's like you know we were
just busy like all the time
now he was also real into the attic like
he kept being drawn up there like it was
all mysterious and everything like that
um he said that he found it really
fascinating like he loved it but he was
also about it really scary
so he's up there one day you know
farting around I don't know what the
hell he was doing up there specifically
looking for something like a screwdriver
I don't know
um and he hears uh creaking like
someone's walking around
and he said that he felt like somebody
was standing in there like watching him
and then there's for some reason this
this little detail was the creepiest
thing to me in the whole episode in the
attic and it's not even paranormal
in the Attic he finds a photograph like
an old photograph that was torn in half
like a picture of a baby that was torn
in half
it's creepy and I was like yeah so if I
found some [__] like that I would be
weirded out and he was weirded out he's
like who the [__] tears a picture of who
he didn't say that but I mean that's
what I would have said but he's like who
tears a baby's picture in half and I'm
like right exactly that's why that's
creepy like to me that's like super
creepy if you found that and like I said
it's not even paranormal there are some
explanations though well yeah I'm sure
but man a little kid found it just turn
it mindlessly tore it could have been
that maybe Pookie did it could have been
that could have been somebody found that
picture it was a picture of them as a
little kid and like yeah I looked like
[__] but what an ugly baby yeah yeah
it was the baby of somebody that they
didn't like like maybe it might have
been a baby of somebody's stepdad
another note was a baby picture or
somebody's hated stepdad oh that's him
[__] him
[Music]
he sucked even as a baby
because I tear a picture I tear up baby
pictures of my stepdad no problem
I tear up pictures of his parents
[Laughter]
Zach says uh well we all know Pookie is
Satan incarnate I mean she's she's a
cute Satan though
she does like to tear [__] up she loves
paper and she'll put her one paw down on
the on one side and then like pull the
rest of it up with her teeth she'll
attack a tablet in the middle of the
night and you're listening to trying to
listen to [__] YouTube and she been
smacking a tablet because something
moved on it
I said leave the tablet alone she loves
tablets you give her another tablet
you're not listening to she's the guy
[__] that tablet I want to [__] up yours
I want yours
you know she goes you're paying
attention to that one so I want that one
she doesn't want you to pay attention to
the tablet right stop looking at those
little people looking into those lights
stop looking at the light yeah she
doesn't understand it yeah well that's
why she kind of gets mad sometimes it
like scratches on the chair and stuff
when we're doing the show because it's
like you people are like looking at the
lights and you're not looking yeah
you're looking at the lights and you're
talking and nobody knows what you're
saying right I don't know what you're
saying
it's like all I know is you're not
paying attention to Pokey right now yeah
yeah
so yeah so he finds this picture that's
like torn and a half there was a baby
and then the back of it he says there
was writing on the back of it that said
Miss Liddell on it and like I said he
thought that was pretty creepy and weird
which it is uh I would I would think
that was creepy and weird if I've had it
in the Attic
and then he sees this was also kind of
creepy I thought this is like a good
effect he sees like this weird
Shadow like it's an attic so it's kind
of like that slanted wall ceiling
situation
so he sees this weird shadow on the wall
that looks like a person like it looks
like the shadow of a person and he's
like he thought at first that it was his
shadow and he's so he's sitting there
going what the [__] like the light is
really weird like casting that shadow
like that far away and then he's like
but he started moving around and Matt
didn't move it just like stood there
like it looked almost like a black
shadow like painted against the wall but
you know I mean like a shadow but there
was nothing casting it
so um he's like well I'm just gonna
pretend I didn't see that maybe I'm just
tired or something like that even though
it was pretty freaky
so uh Rebecca meanwhile uh also has been
looking into the history of the house
and discovers that Liddell who
presumably that's the picture that the
baby was
um died when she was 54 years old and uh
she OD'd she committed suicide so like I
said a lot of people knew that in the
neighborhood it was kind of a famous
story
so Rebecca is home alone one day uh
working on the house or whatever while
Mark is presumably at work and starts
hearing really really heavy footsteps up
in the attic now she does not
immediately think this is a ghost she
thinks well because they've had so many
neighbors and [__] like that like
farting around and wanting to come
inside the house she assumes that
somebody has snuck into the house like
through the Attic So she thinks it's a
person
so she kind of like hears somebody up
there and she's like well [__] and so
she runs and like closes the door like
up to the attic and like pushes a chair
up so they can't get out like if there's
somebody up there in Irving but then
like the footsteps stop
and then she's sitting there thinking
you know maybe all of the [__] that
people are saying about this place being
haunted maybe that's actually true maybe
there's not a person up there maybe it's
a ghost [__] walking around
now they get to a point too where Mark
was sitting there saying uh you know
this house the renovations were um
costing way more than they expected
um the electric bill was way higher than
they were expecting so it's like they
were having a little bit of trouble with
you know money everything was a lot more
expensive than they had anticipated when
they bought the house right
so basically they're so they're saying
again like all of these people keep
coming to the house they said they had a
90 year old woman show up on the
doorstep one day wanted to come in and
then at that point Rebecca's like you
know what why don't we just she's like
Halloween is coming up so why don't we
just open the house to everybody on
Halloween and like charge them to get in
it's like you know we need money so and
everybody wants to get in here so why
don't we just do that like we'll raise
some extra money so we'll like charge a
big five bucks to like come in here or
something like that so that's what they
did they decided they were going to open
the house up on Halloween and let
everybody run around in there
so they said you know we thought we'd be
lucky if we got like 50 people something
like that they said 600 people showed up
they said there was a line around the
[__] block
to go into this house and they actually
had to hire a kid like a student to tour
people around you know what I mean I
think they I hire a couple kids actually
um and they said it was crazy because
some of the people like they were
waiting in line to get in and she's like
then it would be time for them to get in
and she's like and they were like
terrified to come in like they thought
some really bad [__] was gonna happen
she's like it was [__] mind-blowing
so another guy that was on the show like
the real person
his name was Shane Curry and he was one
of the um students that they hired like
to help them like give tours around the
house or whatever
and at this point in the show they kind
of do a flashback because they show like
the student and he's telling the tour
group hey in case you don't know the
history of the house like what happened
here this is what happened so basically
what happened was it was Christmas Eve
of 1948.
now Liddell's mom who I think they said
her name was Patty Allen she's giving
her annual big Christmas Eve party Urban
ever now Liddell uh who's there she's
like a grown woman like I said she was
in her 50s at this point and
um what seemed like real depressed like
real sad but nobody really knew why she
wasn't like talking about it
and they're like basically the end of
the party she kind of like gets a little
plate of hors d'oeuvres or whatever and
like a little glass of punch and she
goes upstairs to her room and basically
she put poison in her punch and drank it
like on purpose and died
um they said she didn't die immediately
actually that she lingered for a while
like it took a week for her to die
I know that I think YouTube [__] I
think the AI algorithm is [__] uh
kind of don't want to talk about
anything about [__] self ending I
think even yeah certain words or kind of
hot spots
don't think because you ingest something
or any of these things these toxic
things that that's an easy way out no no
no no no no no no no no you need to read
the fine print that's a slow miserable
way
I'm bad all right don't do it
all right that's a girl's way
really if you look at the statistics
because they think it's going to be easy
no it's not uh
a lot of times the the guy ways which
are violent gruesome are they're
instantaneous a lot of them yeah you
just kind of leave a mess for everybody
you leave a mess but you know
um
don't do it it ain't worth it in the
past
everybody [__] could stumble in a
moment of weakness but just in a shake
you'll Shake It Off even if it's
something [__] horrendous it might
take it it might take years but
eventually you'll get through it don't
worry about it
you were built to survive
man that light did change
yeah it did and it's now blue Liddell's
doing it yeah
how did it fade to Blue like that
I don't know like it does that randomly
like it's not just that one like some of
the other lights in the room like not
often but every now and then I'll just
be sitting here like not even close to
them or anything and all of a sudden
it'll go do and like change color and
I'll be like all right that is not in
the program they must be wearing out
maybe I mean they've been on for years
yeah I never turned them off right I
just leave them on they don't cost much
we'll get some more rgbs yeah they're
not expensive right I mean they're cool
to have though because it's like you
know I like all the colored lights and
everything
yeah I just think some of them are
getting old we leave them on 24 7. yeah
I mean I always just leave them on it
because it's too much of a pain to like
to turn them off and on and I like to be
able to like you know if I get up in the
middle of night lights go to the
bathroom or come get my phone or
something like that I like to have
lights on so I can see where I'm going
yeah and they were on 24 7 not just here
but at the old house yeah at the old
house we left them all yeah I got strip
lighting around certain [__] where
the ceiling meets the floor it was
actually like white Christmas lighting
that we used outside and said [__] that
I'm gonna put that in the house yeah
so we use those kind of like night
lights and stuff yeah like around the
floorboards or whatever yeah and I got
all these [__] cool ass [__]
projection effects on [__] walls and
on ceilings most of the ceilings have
laser and projection look like swirling
galaxies and [__] and yeah that's what
we have in the bedroom I like that there
were things that came out of my little
gym and things that I collected but I
like lighting effects and we don't
really run with real lights we just use
Smart lights in in the fixtures and I'll
change the colors or get them to pulsate
I like a lot of nightclub color
amusement park yeah I'm not a real big
fan of just regular lights I don't like
direct lighting I kind of I kind of like
Darkness because all this [__] is like
LED it's real efficient
in terms of uh you can leave it on
you're not really burning much
electricity yeah it doesn't it doesn't
[__] uh
it doesn't pull much much wattage yeah
so uh so yeah so Liddell like I said um
she died in 1948
and thereafter her mom
um sealed up the room and wouldn't go in
there like ever again like the room was
sealed up for like many many years
so back in the present uh the tour group
is now in this room where Liddell died
and the guy the kid that was given the
tour said the lights started to Flicker
and then they said that a shirt like
flew out of the closet like across the
room like that
and so everybody that was in the tour
group obviously they thought it was a
gag like they thought oh like how'd you
do that or whatever like is it on a wire
or whatever and Shane's like yeah we
didn't do that that just like did that
by itself we didn't set it up they're
like look go look there's no wires in
there or anything like that so at that
point
um some of the people were just like
yeah we're out all right that's that's
enough ghost for us this evening
and then one woman who was kind of like
at the back of the tour group or
whatever
um she apparently was leaving the master
bedroom and she apparently saw an
apparition of Liddell and she told Mark
this when she was leaving but she was
like super jazzed about it she's like I
saw her I saw her like she was real
excited
um so but she asked him she's like why
is she so sad like I guess her face
looked really sad because nobody knew
like I said that was kind of the big
thing of the story is like she's nobody
knew like why she had uh killed herself
you know what I mean
so after the Halloween party which
apparently they made like some decent
money and everybody got to see the
inside house it was win-win uh so they
kind of go back to their regular lives
but then one day Rebecca is in the
living room I think and she's like
vacuuming and they had this old uh like
antique victrola type situation
and uh they said it came on by itself
and it was one of the ones it was you
know the one of the ones you had a crank
like it wasn't you know what I mean so
it would just kind of come on by itself
in like the old-timey music would play
and [__] which you know that's pretty
creepy
so she decides uh she's gonna go
upstairs and tell Mark about this hey
the record player just came on by itself
but she goes up there and she's in like
the upper hallway or whatever and she
sees a woman like she sees the ghost of
a woman like standing there who she
assumes is Liddell and she said that it
felt like it was controlling her body
for like five or six seconds like
because she kind of like went back and
then she kind of like fell on the floor
and she was like what the [__] and she
was um she said it felt like Liddell was
trying to tell her something
yeah because like you probably won't
make it up make it through there it
doesn't matter freshen my [__] up a
little bit don't take me at all I'm
gonna do half okay I can make more
that's we got a lot more
yeah because I went I went and I got
some orange juice the whole thing with
orange juice on the way home from work
too yeah
um
yeah so Mark is like still not super
convinced because he hasn't really seen
anything all that definitive but he does
say well maybe we should like have a
paranormal group come in here and
investigate like and maybe we can get
some proof that there is actually
something going on in there
so they call this group I think they
said they were called Louisiana Spirits
even though this isn't Louisiana
Louisiana this is Arkansas but whatever
so the woman that they had on there who
was kind of like the head of the
investigation or whatever her name was
best Maxwell and they she was the real
lady was on the show too
um so she gets her team in there
now Mark and Rebecca are gonna go out
for the evening and leave the team there
like to investigate
but Mark he felt like he said on the way
out the house like he was walking down
the stairs he started feeling like
really really
um dizzy or like some kind of weird like
electrical charge or something like that
and it was like kind of weird in the
mouth
so the team
um they basically determine that the
attic is the focal point of The Haunting
which you know that's that's kind of
like uh they sort of knew that already
Mark did
um they were up there and like they said
the EMF meter was like going nuts up
there
and while uh Beth the head of the
investigation while she was up there she
said she heard a woman's voice saying
the name Liddell like a couple of times
and you know there was nobody else in
there so obviously she's like okay well
that was some Spirit activity then
then there was like this other woman
that was like another member of the team
whose name was Rachel and she was in the
master bedroom and she heard
she said it said that she heard a lady
singing quietly like from far away
although on the um show it actually was
just like playing the record again like
she heard the record that Rebecca heard
earlier so I don't know if it was the
same if she actually heard a lady
singing her if it was just the record
playing
and then they said while they were there
you know it's night time
when they're doing the investigation and
they said there was like white flashes
like like it was like lightning like all
around the outside of the house even
though it wasn't storming out
um and then all the power goes out
except for the audio recorders all
stayed on for some reason
um so the first thing they thought well
maybe it was a Transformer blue like
that's what the light was and stuff like
that but then they look out the window
and this house is the only one that
doesn't have any power like everybody
else still has power so obviously it
couldn't be a Transformer and there's
like I said there's no storm or anything
so Mark and Rebecca haven't even got to
wherever the hell they were going I
assumed they were going out to dinner or
something like that they're like they
were only like a few blocks from the
house and they get a call like from the
team and they're like look all the power
went out and it's just this house um so
we don't really know what's going on
so Rebecca and Mark like go back to the
house and they go around the back and a
branch has coming off the tree and um
like Fallen right on the power line and
they said you know yeah that could have
been a natural occurrence but they're
like one it wasn't storming it wasn't
windy and the branch wasn't dead either
so they thought it was like kind of
weird that it just happened to fall on
this power line like right when they
were starting to do the investigation or
whatever
so at this point they're like well we
don't have any electricity so obviously
we can't do much of the [__] we were
gonna do because you know obviously we
need electricity for all these machines
and [__]
but a few days later
this plays some EVPs because remember I
said all the power went out went out but
for some reason the audio recorder
stayed on which they couldn't figure out
so she said we got a bunch of EVPs so
she plays them for Mark and Rebecca and
she said that there was a bunch of
voices on there and they were responding
in the moment like when because when
they were playing it and when the power
first went out and somebody said oh
maybe it was a Transformer there was a
voice saying not a Transformer that's
what the voice said so they said that
there was a lot of things that um seemed
like the voice was answering them or was
like you know and she was specifying
most of the haunting she said that she
investigated were residual hauntings
like they didn't answer your questions
or anything like that but she's like
this was a lot different to that because
it seemed like she was answering
questions or responding to people like
in the moment right how long we've been
going uh 43 minutes do you want to run
any commercials or anything like that no
okay all right people uh super chats are
active and you can always give us a
super thanks if you're listening to this
um
recorded instead of live just uh letting
you all know I'm just passing the damn
passing the damn collection plate around
in church
[Laughter]
we're very we're very very far from
church
this is a different kind of churches
we're more Church of the Sinners we're a
lot more fun than church that's for sure
uh but yeah so best figures well this is
probably Liddell talking and she must
want something like she wants everybody
to know
um you know why she did what she did
because everybody seems to like wonder
about it
so not too long after this
Mark said that he woke up one morning he
said it was a Saturday
and he just for no reason at all felt
compelled to go up to the attic even
though like I said no rational reason
for him to go up there he's like he just
had a very very strong feeling that he
should go up there like as soon as he
woke up
so he goes up there and he ends up being
sort of drawn right to this spot
and he's and it was like behind some
wall boards you know I mean because it
was kind of like the attic thing with
you know the slanted ceiling or whatever
and it was just all these slat like wood
slats
and he was just drawn to this particular
area so he starts pulling the wall
boards out
um and he said he kept hearing like
voices in his head telling him to like
keep looking keep looking
and he said he even thought that he felt
like a hand on his shoulder like trying
to push him forward like yeah you're
doing the right thing or you're in the
right spot or whatever so he pulls out
all these boards
and finds this big brown envelope and it
was full of letters that were all
addressed to Liddell and they were all
from 1948 the same year that she died
um he said while this was all going on
it was like very surreal like he felt
like he was dreaming and stuff
and then like he's looking through the
letters and he looks up and there's like
a white light and he hears somebody
calling his name
and then it like he's like he sees
Liddell for a second but then like it
morphs into Rebecca so it's almost so he
said that it was almost kind of like
Liddell was like because he's like I
sure saw Liddell but then like when he
looked again it was his wife
so he he got the impression that Liddell
was like using her energy to like show
herself for a second or something like
that that's how he explained it
so these letters after they read them
there are 82 letters in there
and apparently what was going on was
that Liddell who like I said a divorced
when she was fairly young and had not
remarried presumably
she had this uh boyfriend Suiter I guess
they would have called it back then
named Prentice Hemingway Savage
motherfucker's name was Prentice and he
was straight and he was straight is that
the most Victorian name that you've ever
heard in your life princess Hemingway
Savage that's pretty fantastic
apprentice apprentice okay yeah with two
s's I'm presuming that's usually how I
see its build
you don't see too many people with a
first name princess I've seen princess
like as the last name a lot but it is a
very weird first name maybe we should
bring that back as a first name no no no
Tom doesn't like that idea
uh so yeah so apparently uh old Prentice
and Liddell had actually dated as
teenagers
um you know and then kind of drifted
apart married other people bloody Bluff
but then
um later on when they were both older
they kind of like re-met and like
rekindled their romance or whatever
only problem with that was that Prentice
was married at this stage
um so I guess at one point they met up
in Milwaukee
and I'm guess I'm you know I'm assuming
they [__] you know yeah I'm just
saying that there was like an affair
going oh [__] happened I think some hook
up [__] happened yeah yeah
um and apparently during this Rendezvous
if you want to call it that
um Prentiss said he was gonna leave his
wife and marry her never ever ever
believe a dude when he says that ever
they all say that but that it's never
that's never they're never gonna do it
at least back in that era yeah that was
kind of like you couldn't do a divorce
back then I mean I think a lot of those
dudes that talked that way in that era
did want the divorce but then they
take out the [__] and then they're like
well you know it wasn't that great
maybe it was yeah and then they're like
and then I'm gonna ruin my reputation
and this and that yeah I kind of think
well and this guy uh old Prentice
Hemingway Savage I feel like you have to
say his whole entire name every time
like because he's super pretentious and
important he was actually at the time
was the vice president of toxico yeah so
he was like very very important and I'm
sure that you know In the Heat of the
Moment
um he's like oh yeah I love you I'm
gonna marry you I'm gonna leave my wife
yada yada but then like when he thought
about it he's like oh like it would ruin
my reputation like everybody like you
know and then the wife will happen and
then she'll take some of my money and
right I guarantee you I guarantee you he
got he got he got them for JJ oh I'm
sure oh yeah and he and he it cooled him
off
well now he did keep writing letters to
her like after a long time and he kept
promising he was fantasizing right he
probably did want to go but the costs
were too great yeah that's what that
deal was with there in that era today he
would have left her
yeah probably yeah I mean it's much
easier now which like I said is that's
good because people aren't trapped into
[__] but you couldn't go where where
your heart desired back in those days
not really you just could uh
the American Victorian era no
yeah most of the marriages were arranged
too especially the Richer you were the
less free you were a lot of myths you
hear all those rich people ran
everything dude everybody else was all
just slaves now the rich people were
more slaves than anybody else because
they couldn't even marry the people they
wanted to marry their dads made them
married people
you know yeah to to form Empires
it was the Mistresses and [__] that that
they chose they didn't choose their wife
yeah in the South me and Jenny are
southern
a rich dude
he loved his mistress not his wife the
wife was just kind of forced on him and
the mistress was usually an octarine
mistress that came out of the dam
Louisiana [__] balls
that's where you got your real wife and
you
raise children with her and gave her her
own house and everything and you had
white women pretending to be octoroons
to get that status
there's a whole culture of that there
but it's just the way it was back then
and nobody was really free
just the the social mores and [__] were
just too [__] strict for rich people
other people are free were poor people
poor people were [__] free they can
do whatever they wanted they were afraid
to starve in a gutter yeah I could also
just do whatever the [__] they want they
can become gunfighters or Outlaws or
hookers or whatever and then like you
know if you were a poor woman you wanted
to be a hooker really a real successful
hooker not a regular one but a real
successful madam was rich and had
[__] powerful [__] boyfriends like
Governors and [__]
well yeah because they had the dirt on
everything they had the dirt on
everything they had a lot of power and
uh a cat house a [__] high-class cat
house that had all the most powerful men
in it every [__] night
and The Madam was like on good terms
with all these guys she could have
[__] killed through these men
you know there's all kinds of [__]
written about an American and she they
were rich
so and
um rich and Powerful a good madam
more so than people realize today
yeah I've read um I read a book a while
back it was not not about the United
States but it was about England but it
was a similar kind of situation yeah and
it was about like four really famous
madams
and yeah it was exactly that they
actually had
you know they they had salons actually
like all these powerful people like all
these most important writers and artists
and stuff would come there and hang out
and it was just like so they were really
being a lady of the evening was not the
same connotation of today
there was no dating in that era you
couldn't date and there were no
nightclubs the closest thing to that was
a cat house madams and Ladies of the
evening
yeah it was all social and they had an
underground power you know you went up
against some [__] badass Madam your
[__] was [__] toast because she was
sleeping with the governor the [__]
chief of police she was Doling out girls
to all their parties and [__] she could
do whatever she wanted she was above the
law people don't realize it women had
power they always had power but might
not have beneficial power that was the
difference well yeah you couldn't really
talk about it you know but they had
gangster power good ones
so I guess what happened with old
Apprentice like we were saying was that
he had written all these well he wrote
82 letters and they said that you know
all these letters were all you know
professions of love and I swear I'm
gonna leave my wife and I'm gonna marry
you and you're awesome and you're the
best thing ever and blah blah
and I guess for a while like Liddell
believed this and was like waiting for
him so they think maybe what happened
um after a while like the letters just
kind of stopped coming he like you know
it was like the early 20th century uh
equivalent of ghosting somebody like he
just stopped writing
and I think they're surmising that she
was expecting him to maybe like turn up
like by surprise like at her you know
her mom's Christmas party which was like
real famous every year and um so she was
waiting to see if he would show up and
he didn't show up and then she thought
well I'm out
they think that that's probably what
happened because she's like she was just
sick of waiting and she didn't want to
wait anymore so that's what she did
um so she just kind of gave up hope
so apparently according to Mark and
Rebecca Spencer who you know allegedly
you know found all these letters in the
wall and you know uh Mark later went on
and wrote a book like I said uh in 2012
it came out and where he talked about
their experiences in the house and he
talked about like he reprinted all the
letters and stuff he thought that uh or
at least this is their story anyway that
they thought they had been drawn to this
particular town of this particular house
um in order to tell Liddell's story to
everybody because she wanted everybody
to know and they were like the right
people to do it for whatever reason so
like I said he wrote a book of what what
did I say it was called a haunted love
story that's right that goes to the
Allen house by Professor Mark Spencer
published in 2012. which I don't I
haven't read I read like little bits of
it but it you know what's interesting I
was reading another thing about this
house like on another on another
paranormal website and they didn't
mention this on the show but apparently
Mark and Rebecca one of the things they
saw they didn't just see
um or one of the things they claimed
that they saw they didn't just see like
uh an apparition of presumably Liddell
but I read somewhere that they also saw
doppelgangers of their own family
members in the house
which that's [__] weird I don't know
why that maybe they thought it would
confuse the narrative like if they put
it in the episode but I was like I kind
of would have liked that to be in there
because that's like pretty [__]
creepy you know
like would it if you're walking around
the house and see like you're [__]
yeah like that's your mom or some [__]
like that it's been reported before in a
lot of uh what they would call hauntings
yeah which I you know I've been looking
at this case and this is classic
haunting
Poltergeist yeah this didn't really have
any Poltergeist type I mean other than
like creaky noises and shirts flying
across the room and [__] like that but
it definitely did seem more like yeah
what they would call an intelligent
haunting like an actual person that had
died there that was trying to like get a
message across I've seen Poltergeist
personally so Jenny I've seen um
bad house a bad house that I think is
just very mild haunting but I've never
seen a haunting like this
so I can't really comment
but when you're watching the uh the
program and you hear in the witness
testimony
they sound credible they saw something I
think
I don't think they're just making it up
yeah they didn't sound like lunatics I
mean they
you know yeah they could they could have
known that the house was haunted ahead
of time because it is quite famous at
least in that part of the country
um you know and thought hey you know
maybe we'll do like an Amityville Horror
thing and yeah all that kind of stuff
and like make some money off it I don't
know how much money they made off it but
a couple of other things that they did
not mention was that I guess the lady
that they bought the house from was
um I think that she was actually I don't
know she was actually like a um of the
Allen family because I know that
uh one of the I think it was Liddell's
sister lived there for a while and she
was the one that had that sealed up
um and she died in the 50s but then they
renovated the house and actually turned
it into apartments that they rented out
to people so there had actually been
tenants in there that
um reported Paranormal Activity even
going back to like a long time ago like
they kept like they would take pictures
and there'd be weird figures in there
like you know Furniture would be
rearranged so it's a long term [__] like
that yeah um something persisted and
like I said a bunch of people would
report walking past the house and seeing
a lady sitting in the window just like
Mark and Rebecca said that they saw
and um I even saw there was one site I
don't remember what site I got this from
but um this one woman who was like a
writer she lived in one of the
apartments and she ended up writing a
novel like that was sort of loosely
based on it would call the scent of
lilacs but apparently there's kind of
like um so all of these other paranormal
groups like I said this is a fairly
famous haunted house in the United
States particularly in that uh state in
Arkansas
um and a lot of people have reported
seeing
an apparition particularly of Liddell
like they'll take a picture and she'll
be in the photo or they'll see her in a
mirror or something like that some
people have also said that they saw
ghosts of three little girls like in the
house playing downstairs uh they're
presuming this might be Liddell and her
two sisters when they were children
they're not really sure
um and there's also like a lot of people
have heard footsteps uh crying
um things like that and
um they also there was one couple that
lived in one of the apartments when it
was apartments for a while and they said
that they had a thing where they were
trying to open the closet door but they
couldn't open it it felt like somebody
was like holding it shut like from the
other side
um and they also heard giggling [__]
like that so it was all that kind of
stuff
um so
that apparently the um
the master suite like where uh Liddell
had died it had been closed up like I
said it was it was closed up for like 30
something years and when a new owner
took over they opened the the thing up
and it's like there was still they said
there was still a bottle of cyanide like
sitting in there that she had used which
that's a bad way to go but yeah
so Mark and Rebecca like I said moved in
now this thing said 2007. I've been on a
haunting they said 2005 so I'm not
really sure like what the timeline is
about that but like I said they said
that they saw their own family members
in there and they did see that like hear
the thing about the victrola and
everything like that but yeah so they
were the ones that uh found the letters
and then they wrote a book about it so
there's that so like I said this is a
pretty famous case pretty famous
haunting I don't know if it really
happened or not but it's kind of a neat
story anyway it fits the pattern of what
you would call Classic haunted yeah
I've never seen classic haunting
I don't know if they exist or not
personally but uh my friend uh Steve
Mara who's a pair of uh parapsychologist
and Paranormal Investigator Jenny's
written some books with him he says it
does
that it does exist based on his studies
I'm not sure if he's actually seen
classic hunting at this level
um
I have to recall if he's actually
witnessed it himself
but
it could have happened it could have
happened I don't think they're making it
up
but for me to be a True Believer I'd
have to see it myself
yeah same yeah I mean because I'm very
very skeptical especially if ones like
this that are like a dead person that's
like trying to communicate with you and
you see them and [__] like that I'm like
that's if that's pretty far out there if
you wanted to see a haunting this this
sounds like maybe a good place to go
into an investigation to see if you can
see one I'm not sure who owns the place
now yeah I mean I know that other
paranormal groups have gone and like
investigated so I'm presuming that
whoever owns it is like pretty open to
having people in there and like filming
shows and stuff the clips of the
witnesses sounded
um credible
this is incredible to me
I think it said it didn't sound like
they were lying sounded like it sounded
like they believed what they were saying
but like I said
I gotta see it
yeah I've seen some wild [__] I know
it's real because I saw it
so I know wild shit's out there but I've
never quite seen this phenomenon no me
neither I'm not gonna say it doesn't
exist it may it may it maybe it does
um
if I went and saw the [__] and and it
and it was real it wouldn't surprise me
that much it was like okay I guess
that's real too yeah yeah
it'd be pretty freaky I'd be pretty
freaky yeah I've never seen an
apparition of a
what looked like a living person or like
a recognizable recognizable human form I
haven't seen it I just saw
uh blue hazes
and kind of like a round ball I guess
but a clear round ball of [__] almost
like a monkey wave or Distortion above
the top of a road you when you look
directly at it you didn't see it but if
you look a little bit to the side you
could see it
it's like something that you're
it's like something that your peripheral
vision could pick up better than your
actual the center parts were you know
where all your rods and cones are there
was nothing there but if you look a
little bit to the side you can see like
a round Distortion and you felt like you
were being watched from that
it was up in the corner of the room up
near the ceiling I'm in red would be
like you see that and go yeah I see it
but you got to look to the side like
yeah yeah yeah it's weird you can't look
directly at it and they're like it's
watching us
yeah [__] like that
yeah read Mammoth Mountain Poltergeist I
tell the whole story
Danny Rowling says Mammoth Mountain
pulls her thrust yeah
that's good we're gonna do it that's
gonna be the porn version
that's good oh that's good that's a good
idea actually we should do like a theme
like that because we're thinking of like
different ideas and stuff yeah I'm
[__] back on the back doggy doggy
style on my hip all of a sudden this
damn [__] dildo flying out trying to
Peg me I'm trying to [__] oh my God
Jenny's got a CG [__] dick
oh my gosh you're gonna figure out how
to do that that'd be [__] hysterical
you got dudes on stream mate trying to
pay to see it happen
if we did that on live stream we would
have to like rig it beforehand so it's
like put them on like some [__]
fishing line or something so it's like
you have like a dildo float they're the
background I've been watching the show I
have been watching the show very funny
what I'm talking about is
hahaha
we're at the club the other night
and our friend Dimitri
and his wife Jan
I've showed you guys to them before they
have some experience in the adult
industry world but not as performers in
that way just
he's like you're gonna do you're gonna
do you're gonna stream mate because yeah
you'd be Cam and he goes what if some
dudes raised a bunch of money to [__]
have Jim Peg you in the house you gotta
do it that was literally the first thing
he asked so that because it's mine
because because that's the [__] and I
was like funnily enough we were just
discussing
he's from The Fetish world so he he
knows how [__] weird some of this
[__] he's DJ'd at [__] High Caliber
fetish events in mansions
where dudes are bringing their wives to
pimp them out to [__] Rich dudes in
these big [__] weird fetish [__]
things and he's like dude man you have
[__] my eyes wide shut up yeah eyes
watch
his wife is beautiful Jen he wasn't oh
hold on that sounded weird he wasn't
pimping her out yeah he was DJing yeah
there okay
but um yeah that sounded weird
but she was like he he instantly jumped
to to [__] like dude you know they're
gonna [__] try to push about but
here's the thing you can always say no
yeah but he's like but but dude what if
they just keep throwing a bunch of money
at you and I'm like going and he's just
like I was like no then he goes oh so if
they throw a million dollars at you you
ain't gonna do it
uh well a million dollars
everyone has a price
you see he can stick a crowdsource that
[__]
you could have a [__] in you
could have a [__] in a chat
who's a billionaire who likes Jenny and
wants to see her [__] Peggy and booty
because he's bi and wants to see you
take it
and I was thinking I was like yeah yeah
but but I went that's a million dollars
though well the thing is if it was a
million dollars hypothetically if it was
a million dollars you'd only have to do
it once you had to do once yeah because
it's like then you'd have a million
dollars so I'm trying to ration because
I'm tired I'm trying to rationalize well
you know I was a [__] soldier in the
Infantry [__] dudes would get
captured by the [__] VC over the
Iraqis and they'd rape them you know
what I mean [__] which that was some
[__] that y'all don't know about
during the first Gulf War some of them
Pilots that got down for bombing and
[__] Baghdad and [__] the ones that
they kept in the damn little [__]
cages and [__] they were raping them
they didn't tell you that but they were
um you didn't want to be a downed pilot
those dudes were pissed off dude because
we were [__] killing millions of
people
[__] bombing [__] Iraqi [__]
anyway uh so I'm like yeah you know
[__] a soldier you might get raped
you know [__] you know I'm like the
thing is is you know it's just Jenny and
they're giving you a million dollars
that's what I mean yeah yeah yeah it's
just me
so anyway [__]
I you know I took his point of like yeah
okay I know what you're saying I just
thought it was very funny that the
second like literally a second after the
first thing that was the first thing he
asked and I thought that was like so
funny because we had literally just been
talking about like this night before it
must have happened it must have happened
to him because that was like the first
like it was like a second that was like
the first thing he asked this is what
you're wrong now when every time I do a
Dimitri I'm going I know what happened
to you I know what happened here
I'm not gonna hurt you okay I'm not
gonna hurt you I'm not gonna let those
men hurt you I'll protect him
oh my God you ready to go I guess
all right so uh you know hopefully you
guys enjoyed a haunting Mondays today
about the Allen house with a little bit
at the end here with the with our usual
thing
but uh yeah so tomorrow night you're
probably going to bike night right yeah
I think so and uh uh then I'm gonna do
some other stuff and then Wednesday
night
oh it'll be a good show Wednesday night
this was a recommendation that somebody
gave me and this was actually a great
idea
we are going to do a revisit
on the
um huasion serial killer case from South
Korea now we did a show about this uh
years ago it was we didn't do a whole
show about it because I think we did two
South Korean cases we did uh huasion and
then we did the frog boys
um but someone informed me I didn't even
[__] know this but the hawas young uh
serial killer case has been solved they
caught the guy huh so after all this
time like in 2019 2020 they came out and
announced that they uh that they had
caught him so that's what we're gonna do
so we're gonna like revisit that do a
deep dive on that um so if you don't
know about that case like I said it was
a famous case that happened in South
Korea if you've seen the um bong Joon Ho
movie uh memories of murder which is an
amazing amazing movie by the way came
out in 2003
um and I really recommend it if you like
Murder Mysteries and thrillers and stuff
um it was kind of based on that like
it's pretty closely based on
on the last young but he hadn't been
caught at that time but he's been caught
now so um yeah so we're gonna do a
revisit on that so that should be a good
show so that's Wednesday night so
hopefully you guys can come by and see
that and uh yeah so have a good rest of
your evening you guys have a good day
tomorrow whatever it is that you're
doing and we will see you again on
Wednesday night good night